what is up there reject nation greg and
john here today so we're going to do
something a little bit fun
different
might not look different from the title
but it's going to be my brother has a
channel called get jaby and they've
launched a new segment here where his
best friend a guy who i really like a
hell of a lot dude named trey hilarious
awesome insightful really knows his
stuff they're starting to do their own
easter eggs breakdown in comparison and
they start with what if episode one and
my brother was like hey why don't you
tell me how to make this better like can
you review the video for me and see
what's all good about it and i said i'll
do you one better i'll have a camera
pointed at us we'll criticize the crap
out of it on camera and you guys can
give your suggestions too let's see what
how this all goes let's see if trey
lives up to the breakdown game
welcome back to jabby's channel i'm
cynthia with the intel and we are going
to break down what if episode 1 there
will be spoilers this episode is based
off of captain america the first avenger
a lot of the scenes are almost identical
with the first avenger here are just a
few that stand out captain carter's suit
is almost identical to captain america
with the exception of the union jack on
her chest and the union jack on the
shield other than that pretty close so
far well edited captain britain with the
exception of the shield of course who is
captain britain you ask think of him as
kind of like a captain america who was
given their super powers through magic
from merlin instead of super soldier
serum peggy handles her transformation
okay okay unlike steve rogers where most
of the time in the machine he's
squealing like a little kid you're
supposed to be captain america man up
rogers peggy never lets out a squeak as
her cellular foundation is being
rewritten in real time she even gives
more blood than rogers rogers may have
shown his strength knocking down a few
punching bags but peggy was redecorating
the wall with over 17 steel weight
lifting plates don't ever let anybody
tell you girls are tough all right
sintel what i'll say is i like that
you're really elevating peggy carter
here captain carter actually i've seen a
couple of breakdowns so far and this is
the first one i'm seeing that's really
going out of its way to describe how
much stronger initially
both mindset and physicality peggy is up
front which is the point of this episode
is just to make us hate steve in
comparison yeah man yeah
this video's woke
man girl power dude even in a what-if
scenario
crap
i hate that complaint for this episode
it says i think that's such a silly
thing to say keep your politics out of
my hypothetical scenarios howard stark
is more than just the country's greatest
mind he also has a great fashion sense
when he gave peggy her suit for the
first time he presented to her in a box
leave with howard's designer clothing
now if you think this is hot you should
see a spring collection
[Music]
howard stark obviously feels a little
more driven
not only did he put her suit in a pretty
box he also already had her shield
painted and ready to go meanwhile rogers
had to pick his unpainted shield up off
the floor come on man
i was before
but you know what that means maybe we
should call this segment peggy carter is
too damn op peggy hops into the real
world and give her powers to spin for
the first time let's just say finesse
isn't really her cup of tea instead sure
she's british
she throws her shield with a sniper's
precision look how far this throw is
that's like a quarter mile life just
seems to be all around better when peggy
carter's wielding the shield even
prisoner experimentation takes a pause
when carter is in town
that's true you know actually that's a
good point peggy really did get a handle
on all this
exceptionally fast yep
she was ready she didn't even need the
shield to start doing those throws
it seemed like she was discovering her
powers and strength in the middle of
executing a perfect fight
and i give you look back at that seat
she is like just amazed by wow look how
great i'm doing i wonder if i could do
greater
bucky is no longer on hydra's
experimentation table instead he's
hanging out with his friends waiting for
the rescue i'm here for sergeant barnes
who are you supposed to be queen of
england hulk buster hydra stomper it
really doesn't matter when a starker's
involved all it takes is just a little
bit of tesseract power unlike tony
stark's first design howard stark's suit
of armor is considerably more modern for
something made in the 1940s even the
heads up display shows jarvis-like
technology reflecting dials and knobs
and gauges it looks like it's blend
between the iron giant and the hulk
buster steve rogers yeah
absolutely hello brooklyn on the suit's
arms this is a notable change from the
original movie captain america in the
first avengers the bombs that would be
dropped on american cities are listed by
name inside of the red skull's massive
bomber the valkyrie things get a little
jazzy for peggy's montage scene as she
wrecks havoc among hydra's forces all
the while cloud-surfing on the back of
steve rogers hydrostomper is it just me
or did the hydra stompers take off feel
a lot like the iron giants when he
learned to fly for the first time that's
a good cause good comparison and steve
have a heartfelt moment over a stiff
drink in one world they're both sitting
in a bar that was once filled with life
and celebration now it's in complete
ruin destroyed from the war steve sits
reflecting if he had done everything
possible to save his lost friend bucky
in peyton carter's universe the bar is
untouched they both enjoy their drinks
and really get to know one another they
profess their mutual respect adoration
and an awkward love towards one another
okay you know i gotta say i thought we
were just walking into a shorter version
of like an eric vos video but i like how
this is a focused pretty much comparison
between captain carter and captain
america the first avenger like yeah so
that's a big like similarities and
differences breakdown of it you're doing
something different sintel making me
appreciate the episode more in the
process now if only you could fix some
of the you know keying on the green
screen here in your video
tell what gives you then it would have
been perfect expect more of you on this
first video let's talk choo choos
training pass scene is where the
differences really stand out this is
where bucky barnes slips and falls to
his presumed death instead peggy saves
him when he's about to fall to his death
you almost ripped my arm off lose his
left arm too in case you're the party
trained
you think everything is going to end all
hunky dory the train is rigged with
explosives and boom goes the dynamite
fortunately steve and his hydro stomper
are there to absorb the blast kind of
like that moment when steve falls on
that grenade when he's in boot camp
ah yeah yeah
steve the hydro stomper
that is actually what's happening
correlation destined for bucky's fate
the hydra stomper is captured and
displayed in the same fashion as
leonardo da vinci's vitruvian man now
according
between the human form and the universe
is this something red skull is trying to
achieve by making an example of those
who stand in his way steve laying on the
ground wakes up and tells bucky that he
has to get back into the suit the charge
of the suit like frankenstein's monster
throws steve in the back and send him on
his way but not before he falls flat on
his face this is a throwback to when
tony stark was first learning how to
use hey
a lot of people have been calling that
the first iron man suit there's one way
to look at that hydra stomper and so
yeah throwing it back to the first iron
man suit
there's a lot of really really charming
all right sintel you're just deleting my
cynicism here
over what we were about to watch
i was ready to rain hell upon you this
is a character arc you're witnessing
peggy discovers where hydra's hideout is
located and she infiltrates it very
similarly to the opening sequence on the
ship in captain america winters yeah hey
that's that's a great call
sure unleash
some hydra-like beasts to inflict his
will in the world it doesn't really go
as planned and he ends up getting
squashed like a bug and tossed into the
back of the portal like a bag of
stinking old trash so peggy gets pinned
against the wall by why couldn't it be
hot he happens to be conveniently next
to a sword that she uses to hack off the
tentacles of the soul of the hydra
monster and gets free now she's carrying
a sword
and a shield
like a knife
shield she found
hey
that is cool i like that i thought of
like a night i think like most people
would say at night but sort of like
jordan shield yeah yeah absolutely two
offset agencies here in the marvel
cinematic universe and peggy carter's
responsible for him both
responsible for shield
i i know
i'm sure she's holding both now so now
i'm giving her credit for both
because what if
yeah
rogers and all of his usefulness
distracts the hydra monster long enough
for peggy to push it back into the
portal now we're getting to the part of
the show where it gets a little choked
up because you know somebody's gonna die
now comes that point when the heroes
have to make the choice and peggy's
about to make hers because she has to
push the hydra monster through the
portal but before she does she remembers
that she's supposed to have a dance with
rogers
rodgers looks out to her along and she
says yes
saturday night
before she plunges into the depths of
the unknown kind of like how rogers
plunged himself into the depths of the
ice you see how this is working right
it's coming together support this
channel by clicking the subscribe button
hitting the like button and also leaving
a comment thank you so much for your
time my name is sintel and i'll talk to
you later
i did a good job he did
he did a good sintel you've earned a
round of applause today way to go way to
go these are the only breakdowns worth
watching now well edited some good
points but sintel thoughtful cintel i'll
say though i know your personality and
while your energy here is good i want to
see more of that energy from you
you are annoyingly energetic in real
life
frustrating as hell to be around like
get away from me man we don't need
this much energy every single time but
that will work great in a youtube video
so pump it up man pump it up to the
point where people will call you fake
that's what i want to see out of you sin
till but now it's good you know it's
like there's a lot of breakdown easter
egg videos up there but i liked how this
was mainly a focused comparison and
especially for this show that felt like
absolutely appropriate and and he
managed to highlight stuff that other
folks happened i thought i would have
more crap to say i know i really did
right i set up this video with the
intention of laying down some crap and
all it really was was the keying on the
green screen from time to time
fix that green screen
but guys subscribe to get jaby keep a
lookout for more of these from them
subscribe to them so you get notified
right when they're up because i think
this is a different thing to start
incorporating into you got canadian lad
who does watching things in ridiculous
slow motion you got eric foss the epic
breakdown like 30 minutes and you know
you got like heavy spoilers and screen
crushed recordable
similar category i like these like bite
size versions yeah i do too it's nice
too bite-sized and thoughtful that's the
name of my bum that i don't have more
crap to say i know you i thought you
were going to unload man
here i was expecting a little bumped out
too we'll have to find another [ __ ] i
wanted to say i want more crap to say so
people aren't like you're just being
nice because it's intelligent on your
brother's channel but yeah
well all right yep all right see you
guys
[Music]